Oh what is going on YouTube check it out
so recently you guys told me about a
video called Facebook parenting for
those of you who do not know what this
video is about this video is about a
girl who decides to write a response or
a facebook note about how she feels
about her parents in this know she
basically wrote how horrible her parents
are making her do all these chores and
how stuff you know my kids are supposed
to do but her father decides to respond
by posting up a video of himself
responding to the mill on Facebook which
later he put on a YouTube account now
this really got me to think what would
happen if a Korean pair found out and
decided to do a video response and this
is what I came up with check it out yeah
you got to pin an egg on GC Gerard likes
accordion shiba not linked up to the
secular ma Nia I think it is nice to I
had me said the lies about her she says
to bury each of big the man huh okay
okay twice Gemma she put it on the Lisa
why so what's a book face she a puka
face it he said what my face book you
thought as a daddy never pine nuts about
Ibuka face up knocking huh
I know everybody singing sir daddy I
know what EJ you're my dad it woke up or
Samsung I know used to order computer
among tonight the cow you write a bad
thing it's about a mommy and daddy okay
she took you DISA what my daughter wrote
about it mommy and daddy okay I'm not
your damn a saber
each or not to my responsibilities to
clean up or your sheets and ma she they
said yeah so you got you a saber yeah
slave I never talked about commence that
she's sick yeah if you want a guard and
shopper the fertilizer yourself don't
wanna see to bake on your answer it's a
watch me do it
Danny shoveled Lukey himself aha you
shovel Dukey you take care not to the
beach get Thank You Danny not a three my
poor thousand miles to come to America
the shovel Dookie dance see your job
you'll pay me at least once a day
it's again a dhaba but you should just a
pay me for the [ __ ] I do around the
house sir you'll get to leave
in my house best to pay for you daddy
growing up he said never have a prank
nobody's the daddy pray nobody helping
daddy out used to I go I shovel dirt
that nobody gave me money and it beat up
us seeks the most Korean in two seconds
every day he's two I get a home from
school I have a new dishes to clean the
countertop
he's a peanut poor he said do the bed he
said laundry time he's okay you're never
help of Danny you got used to do
whatever you like but you don't come
home to me
you're coming home you're dead if I say
you do laundry so you do your laundry
you don't want to touch a daddy
underwear
so you either put but you don't want to
clean the dish after you eat the food
you should go do it in your underwear
but you don't want to clean up duty and
on the last note you a son you did he
said I'm not daddy not a say oh you die
like a joke no you come home you sir die
you die you'll be so what go to squeeze
are you oh I know what is the best for
you I go to sleep at a pen every night
because I so tired I stay up I cannot to
stay up and do anything else sir I have
to get up in a pine a.m. in the morning
to go to school
oh you have to go to school dance for
your job you have a keep it television
you have my shoes you have a put what
after you need yeah you want a boyfriend
I kill him you know you said your
comparison my life is so hard
daddies I went to church every Sunday on
a mountain he's I climb a mountain in
the snow I'm going to hate to see the
day so you get all to wiper your own
answer and you caught me poor help
I want to be there don't you think you
say you're out the limit daddy huh
daddy secure you before you kill me
nobody I don't cook what you disco pop
oh oh oh
Shimokitazawa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm like so bored I'm drunk it's the
freakin weekend baby I'm about there
have me some fun